years I've only seen this doll for five
minutes at full and I'm already
believing help today we're going to be
talking about the movie Annabelle and
it's soon to be really sequel Annabelle
creation what doll the Linnet waitress I
guess it's a prequel I don't know
definitely a prequel and about is a
spin-off to the conjuring series haunted
dolls are a staple of course ago from
Chucky to that clown doll and
poltergeist that I don't really want to
talk about Annabelle is the latest
addition to this terrifying lineup of
spooky places today's episode if you
haven't guessed we're going to live with
haunted dolls for this challenge Niall
and I will buy allegedly haunted dolls
from the weird part internet live with
those dolls for 24 hours and if our
bodies in Soul survive we'll return here
to determine whether the experience of
living with a haunted doll refresh or
just plain rock so you actually believe
in haunted dolls I believe in energy i
plan on trying to make the dolls haunted
as possible you need Jesus I'm going to
name my doll Annabelle creation
[Music]
[Laughter]
you should get me a black or brown woman
doll this one with missing eyes no when
it comes to the supernatural I'm more
cautious and scared about it the problem
is a lot of these dolls are especially
pale give me a creepy little white girl
why not
this isn't 75% off it looks kind of
racist the worst thing that could
possibly happen is kind of feeling like
there's a presence always with me
afterwards this one's name is Emily who
is a very important and well-loved
schoolteacher she devoted her life to
helping children in bad neighborhoods
Emily's created very active she loves to
talk and helps children you should get
that one for your I'm doing this all for
you I'm a pretty rational person I'm
pretty logical I want you to find me the
most haunted worst story doll really
demented messed up okay just nothing
sticky why would you possess a doll if I
could possess something I possess like a
space shuttle
psychic paranormal metaphysical EVP
porcelain spirit all this sounds pretty
promising her name is Anastasia she lost
her life during the tragic volcanic
eruption do you think they asked her
that way did you die in a volcano yeah I
would love to be murdered by a girl I
like her she seems cool okay
I was feeling a little uneasy so I
decided to talk to Ryan vegara who is
our resident ghost hunter here he had
actually gone to an island full of
haunted dolls
my goal is to save face how do I do that
if I were you I would just hunker down
leave in an infertile area do not
communicate it don't touch it I was
thinking like she just needs a friend
and so I'm like maybe I was hoping that
he would give me a little bit of advice
and a little bit of hope the spirit is
trapped in something I can't imagine a
lot of good reasons for that if it's a
demonic presence it could be a become a
parasite in your life they could ruin
your life literally you could kill you
even I'm so glad I'm not doing this in
you are there was a long life I'd wake
up screaming I woke up in Miami Gaara is
useless we finally got the dolls in the
mail wake up okay wake up everybody it
was kind of like the opposite of opening
your presents for Christmas it's
adorable oh hello ma'am
she's pretty Wow look at this dress
you're gonna live your life I'm going to
live my life and she did your name is no
longer Anastasia your name is Annabelle
creation all right get this little
friend oh [ __ ] Oh
oh my God look at this dogs already
fighting back there's just this metal
like de poll that or something that's
like I've only seen this doll for five
minutes and I'm already bleeding
you're already taunting it really and
then you get stabbed I'm stoked all
right it's [ __ ] on I just get this
day done and over with
guys this young lady used to be named
Anastasia my desk mates really did not
take to Annabelle creation where are you
going two of them basically fled Becca
give any idea strategies to how to get
her to haunt me
they sort of wished that that doll would
teach me a lesson and make me a little
less insufferable want me so far all
you've done is stabbed me once nyla how
are you feeling I'm fine where's your
dog he's living her life and I'm living
my life so far it's been going pretty
well
I mean she's looking at me I'm not
looking at her I think this establishes
a relationship of dominance for me so
she knows who's in charge Garrett has
been doing the complete opposite of what
I've been doing he's been carrying his
doll by the hair is your name Annabel
creation this is pretty dumb I think
we're both too sort of pushing it off
yeah I'm going to possess this coin with
the OED board we'll put the little
portal viewer on it and now this is a
haunted coin are you possessed by a
spirit head yes tails now yes that's a
yes
she really was very true to herself with
every question I asked are you going to
murder me that's a head so boy I'm glad
now you is Emily Nyla's doll going to
murdered nyla at the tail whoa nobody's
going to murder nyla can I ask a
question please are you going to murder
me or anyone that I low in love that's a
head [ __ ] man that was really fact so
the rest of the day I tried to give her
every advantage I could to make her
potential as a haunted object sign
through
[Music]
there's not like barking out or scared
or anything these things it smells weird
because it's an old dumb dog
oh come on and I'm Taiwan a refuge as
the day came to an end I realized this
doll and I were just going to be alone
when I got home
best of luck Garrett sure you have our
dolls give up now cuz you've been doing
drugs that all no I'm good here we go
alright I just got home from work
thinking about what I want to eat for
dinner and also remembering that I need
to take this young lady with me wherever
I go
the doll is in my bag but before that
was where's Oh might have been a stage
piece okay I'm freaking myself out got a
show
I really just staged every single
doorway the inside of my closet which is
probably a fire hazard but it's okay now
ELISA does not play I even staged my cat
he was not feeling it come here Lenny
let me just stage you there we go I'm
taking a dark way home if she was
looking for an opportunity she'll find
one for most the rest of the evening it
was very easy to ignore Annabelle I made
sure she was staring at me the whole
night she was right next to me while I
was doing a crossword puzzle I didn't
even notice
do something it's time for bed the doll
is over there she's asleep right there I
will see happy
good night Annabelle creation good night
[Music]
it's morning Buddha Hall is stills where
I left it I woke up this morning happy
to still be alive I was happy to not be
possessed woke up an hour before my
alarm completely refreshed the one odd
thing was that Annabelle was no longer
beside me she could quick scan of the
room and I saw that she had just fallen
off the bed like a stupid extra pillow
overall I found the experience of living
with a haunted doll a bit disappointing
I was pretty bored I was never murdered
and actually carrying around this cursed
doll became kind of a burden all that
considered I have no choice but to call
the experience wrong living with haunted
doll was unpleasant it really validated
that I loved living alone and I ignored
it and I will continue to ignore it for
those reasons I also read the experience
as long I think I want to resell my doll
and let somebody else enjoy there should
be friends oh yeah we should sit on it
like I do - haunted doll one's a very
very naughty girl but one's a very very
good girl